all right let's check in on the great
toy drive this time Rocky went to Telus
International the sponsors of this
segment to see what's under the tree for
some special kids
you have till Friday to get your toys in
for the great toy drive one of our
sponsors tell us International has a
beautiful tree and lots of toys under
the tree right now but before that let's
talk about Telus what do you guys do
so we're a global organization made up
of over 70 000 team members across 28
countries and we deliver Next Generation
digital and customer experience
solutions for different top Global
Brands wow that's amazing so you guys
one of your slogans is we give where we
live so besides all of that that is
another one of your primary things you
do here absolutely one of the things
that's most important to tell us is
being able to give back to the local
communities where our team members work
and live and many of our team members
have families of their own so volunteer
initiatives that focus on local children
are very much near and dear to their
hearts and it enables us to deliver on
our brand promise of we give where we
live absolutely now let's get to why
we're here we're here for the great toy
drive and I have to say the community
came out and supported here at Telus
what have you guys gotten so far I see
chess I see jackets yeah so lots of
variety
um we've had our own team members come
and provide a toy ways we've also had
different community members just come
here and drop off donations so we've
gotten toys for girls boys as you can
see we even got clothes which is amazing
so that's unique I haven't seen that yet
so that's really great you guys can also
donate clothing yeah definitely so we're
encouraging everything anything that's
going to help out the kids you know and
what exactly are there any rules for
people who are coming here to donate I
know you want unwrapped toys right yeah
so any new unopened toys you can bring
in during business hours we have until
Friday so still plenty of time to drop
off toys the bins are right here in the
front lobby so it makes it super easy
and quick for anyone to donate and when
you do walk through these doors to
donate you can also talk to the staff
about hiring tell us about your team
here definitely so we're always looking
for Motivated high energy engaged team
members to join our amazing team we love
to hire within our communities and we
have an amazing team of recruiters right
here on site that are happy to talk
about our different job opportunities
for different customer service positions
Karen thank you guys tell us
International you guys are giving back
to the community in more ways than one
look at this spread for our kids
benefiting the shade tree the great toy
drive is over on Friday so bring your
toys in
thank you to everyone who has given and
will be giving the eight news now great
toy drive is in full swing and we're
collecting toys and gift cards to
benefit the shade tree you can drop
donations off at Telus International
until this Friday